[Music]
so I'm going to talk for about 30
minutes on some core ideas around what
makes us a primate special different
compromised excited in the digital world
within which we live now you might think
from all the hullabaloo that AI is a
brand new subject sadly not if you get
there is a very youthful me there it
looked like some kind of rather bad
album cover this is 1978 1978 and this
department of artificial intelligence
University of Edinburgh we were busy
doing AI there were PhDs in it there
were departments of it despite the best
efforts of the UK government to close it
down there had been a thing called the
light Hill report so James light Hill
Lucchese and professor of mathematics in
Cambridge no less for a EIN robotics
were load of rubbish and and the UK
should disinvest we kind of saw that AI
winter through and and through a number
of cycles of investment disenchantment
investment dissing charmin we've had
about four or five different enthusiasms
for AI usually centered around a moment
when something remarkable happens
usually to human specialists ability and
I'll try and explain why this has been
going on where we at the moment would
that be different
etc so the the the book diversion here
this has just come out in the states
with a rather fetching cover but the
books been out for about a year there
are copies here if you're so interested
you'll notice from the title that it
owes a little bit to this wonderful book
okay which is Desmond's Desmond Morris's
wonderful book fifty years ago published
a real bestseller I have to say in which
he took time to explain
we're primates we are full of primate
urges we are evolved as primates we
better understand our fundamental human
nature into
tens of zoology and various
anthropological studies as well and you
know despite Darwin being mainstream for
best part of the century this was still
kind of a moment when people when we
really are the the best chapter in the
book is often described as the one on
sex it still reads rather well but it
what it actually what you absolutely do
get from the book is this sense of just
how much of our fundamental nature we
owe to our animal origins and just to
expand on that the first part of our
book which isn't our March to Desmond
Morris in some respects begins a long
way back he begins actually with a
primate for bear
this is Australopithecus afarensis they
were roaming around on the African
savannah well for the north and that
probably three and a half million years
ago and they were also remarkably making
tools okay now this is all very recent
it's pushed back the history of
tool-making amongst our hominid
forebears by a million years at least
and this was relatively relatively
advanced although primitive tool making
it is dated reliably to three point
three million years ago that means I ask
you to think about this that for 200,000
generations more or less before we even
arrived on the scene Homo sapiens
arrived we're busy making tools and all
the evidences is that tool making shaped
on urology or fine-motor precision
possibly as a driving function on our
language and our planning and we were
certainly getting very good at it by the
time Homo sapiens arrived and a member
of our family
two hundred hundred thousand years ago
was able to perfect and then develop a
range of stone age implementation that
was screw each quite extraordinary but
for two hundred thousand generations
before that our technology was in the
hands literally of our predecessors
there's a really interesting point to
bear in mind here oh we didn't just make
our technology our technology made us
okay and it's always been the case and
the question we're asking ourselves now
is what is the hand-axe of the 21st
century or the supercomputer in your
pocket or the smartphone doing there is
one fundamental difference of course
which is that we have very little
appreciation of the device we carry
around in our pockets we certainly
couldn't make one not even Tim
berners-lee or the best engineer on the
planet could make one from start to
finish let alone write the applications
that run on it but it is one of the
universal tools of our culture and our
age as we kind of do this breakthrough
this fly through to a chip on an iPhone
we're down at the feature scale this is
15 nanometers these are the gates inside
the iPhone actually the Apple a8 process
of this is a few years out of date
interest to me but even so 15 nanometers
you could get 460 of these features 460
of these gates inside a single red blood
cell okay now it's very hard for us to
appreciate these orders of magnitude one
of the reasons why we get a bit blown
away by what happens is that when things
double and this is the famous Moore's
law where you've got number of
transistors on the chip as against the
year of introduction these things change
so fast we are taken by surprise when we
look at the computing power that's on
offer on what we can do with that I
should say by the way that video you saw
earlier already exactly 50% out of date
ok the chip that many of you may be
running the a12 Bionic has nearly 7
billion transistors on it the feature
size is around about 7 to 8 nanometers
ok now people will tell you this is all
going to run out there's all sorts of
interesting reasons why in physics we
might hit the buffers but actually I
think our ingenuity in the way we build
these architectures is
is really extraordinary we'll carry on
periodically things change this
wonderful picture is of Kasparov holding
his head in his hands the previous AI
apocalypse before this one was widely
touted in 1997 20 years or so ago the
machines were going to take our jobs
they're gonna wake up they're gonna take
care of all the jobs we did because well
a human was beaten at a very very
difficult game that we kind of prized as
a feature as an aspect of our human
intelligence chess and it was a
difficult challenge not least because
your average game of chess has a search
space which in about the mid game
halfway through a game of chess if I've
got four plays open to me and my
opponent has there are about 650 billion
possible moves just in that piece of
what we call the game tree that's a lot
to compute with okay but the
supercomputer of the time IBM's deep
blue was searching between 100 and 200
million positions a second two things
that's a lot of power or was then and it
upturned a lot of views about what
wasn't wasn't possible
no human being searches a hundred to two
hundred million positions a second the
system that beat Kasparov that had him
holding his head his hands didn't play
chess in any way that is remotely human
okay but of course actually at certain
points Kasparov thought it might thought
it might be reading his mind didn't know
what was going on he was literally
unnerved by the system Kasparov writes
very well about this experience and is a
very thoughtful commentator on where
modern AI is there's another world-class
champion holding his head in his hands
this is Lisa doll the world's best go
player that was thought to be well
beyond the power of any computer to
solve because well there are a lot of
positions in the big game of a game of
go in fact every position every move in
a game of go probably has 250 odd
possible next move
the search space is insane but
nevertheless the computers of the day
which we'll talk about a little bit were
capable of searching that space and with
the way we program them now doing more
than that
finding the patterns beating the world's
best go player does that mean we are
redundant well we'll come back to that I
think not but it does mean we live in a
world of extraordinary AI embedded
everywhere and by AI I don't mean the
self-aware reflective computer of
Terminator or how or not so reflective
in terminators case but certainly in
house case this is about systems that
can recognize your voice or answer a
question about general knowledge by
using all the data on on the web or
driving a car of performing robotic
surgery and we can look at that and get
a bit unnerved ourselves we shouldn't
okay we shouldn't just yet and where it
does become alarming we should exert
some moral agency over this whole
process and ask ourselves what do we
actually want to happen with this
technology to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas